si une in the next one day à la gare de
versailles hermance est en contact toute
la journée avec des touristes du monde
entier
étudiante en deuxième année de bts
tourisme son rôle et simples mais
essentielles répondre aux nombreuses
interrogations que peuvent se poser les
visiteurs étrangers ou français à
certaines questions de vue que c'est pas
le connais pas énormément la région
c'est surtout ça qui est compliqué mais
on apprend sur le tas y au fil des jours
on commence à connaître les questions se
répète donc on a eu une mauvaise
expérience en venant ici on a acheté le
mauvais ticket et la police nous a mis
une amende
maintenant elle je la remercie elle fait
du bon boulot oui oui elle nous est
vraiment mais elle n'a pas encore fini
en tout 200 gilets violets sillonnent
les principaux sites franciliens pendant
les fêtes de noël une approche pour
tenter de séduire à nouveau les
visiteurs après les événements tragiques
de ces derniers mois en 2016 la région a
perdu près d'un milliard et demi d'euros
de recettes touristiques s'agit pas
uniquement de les orienter
mais aussi de leur dire que paris et
d'ile-de-france regard regorge de mille
richesses et qu'on est aussi capable de
les emmener faire un bateau un tour de
bateau sur la seine
un cabaret une croisière ce genre de
choses dont les yvelines les volontaires
du tourisme sont également déployés
devant le château de versailles
l'opération si elle s'avère efficace eux
rempli fier l'an prochain